okay let's go next to the five six two
area code five six to welcome if you can
hear me five six to jump right into your
question hey David I'm a big fan this is
Melinda Melinda go ahead I'm Long Beach
hey um so I was kind of following the
election in Italy and it got me thinking
about parliamentary systems versus like
a democratic republic and I was thinking
do you think that's a more fair system
and theory it's certainly more fair in a
lot of ways right and so in a
parliamentary system you would have so
currently let's say you have I don't
know just for picking something let's
pick the Libertarian Party 435 House
races in the United States you might
have libertarian candidates in a hundred
of those races who might be able to get
seven percent of the vote in each of
those hundred races but they don't win
any race at all and then libertarians
end up with zero representation out of
the 435 members of the House of
Representatives if we had a sort of
representative parliamentary system if
together all of those libertarian
candidates were able to put together say
two percent of the vote that would get
them roughly eight or nine seats in the
House of Representatives so I think it's
a very interesting system and I've
expressed that I like it in many ways I
think there is zero chance that we would
ever even come close to having that in
the United States just requiring require
changing so much of our infrastructure
set up yeah definitely well I mean also
with I thing about gerrymandering too
because the you know we with
gerrymandering it's rigged over here do
they have kind of a way to rig it I
don't know too much about parliamentary
system John askew but you know they can
kind of rigged the district so over here
yes my representative
well the parliamentary system also has
as a feature that it is particularly you
can do even more dan
and create even more havoc with the way
that the sort of districts are selected
when then you have a parliamentary
system okay Melinda thank you so much
for your question have a big crush on
you by the way I'm sorry what was that
I hope meant you crush on me by the way
all right very good well please do
calling again all right we'll talk to
you later
well she's gonna hang up right after
saying that yes nobody stayed up very
polite so I was able to really follow up
and and figure out what on earth is
going on